the crazy thing right now is uh Michael
Rapaport if you saw on Instagram if you
go to follow him on Instagram right now
it gives you the warning that says this
account posts um like controversial
thing no no not not controversial it's
like fake and misleading oh is it got as
soon as he said he'd vote for Trump they
got him isn't that crazy someone sent
that to me I go I couldn't believe it I
have to see for myself and it literally
says if you go follow Michael rap we'll
pull that up we'll pull that up in I
have it I took a screenshot of him my
phone and uh cuz I'm like Rapaport you
think that guy's been orange man bad for
but he just came out and said he's he's
considering voting for Trump says this
this are you sure you want to follow
Michael Rapaport this account has
repeatedly posted false information that
was reviewed by independent fact
Checkers or went
against this is why they need to destroy
X Elon Musk shattered a large portion of
their narrative control